more we're joined by Barbara Slavin the
director of the Atlantic Council's
future of Iran initiative she's in our
Washington bureau this morning Barbara
good morning good morning the president
says he did this to prevent war Rand
Paul says he believes we are now going
to go to war whose rights
well I'm afraid Rand Paul may have the
the better argument here but what I see
are winners and losers winners from this
are Isis al Qaeda Sunni fundamentalists
that hate Iran as well as the United
States Russia China which will become
more powerful in the Middle East in a
strange way I think Donald Trump is
engineering the u.s. withdrawal from the
Middle East
because as has been pointed out it will
be untenable for American forces to stay
in Iraq probably Syria we will see a
drastic drawdown in American diplomats
American tourist business people are
going to be forced to think more about
their security because of this it was a
stunningly can I say stupid and
counterproductive move on the part of
the United States and we're going to pay
the price for this and the people of the
Middle East will pay the price for this
for years to come it sounds like we're
saying that this is simply not a
one-and-done in our part I think back to
shock and awe mission accomplished
not happening here very much not and you
know the idea that one man somehow will
determine Iran's policies the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard Corps is a very
large organization the Kurds force the
elite force is a very large organization
he has been replaced there are people
with deep ties to a variety of groups in
the Middle East this policy will
continue killing sulemani does nothing
but feed Donald Trump's ego and distract
attention from other issues involving
him very temporarily Barbara there's
been so much talk over the last day or
so about the idea that there has been
the ability for the u.s. to do something
like this previously but they have not
there has been restraint this happens
now but you say this started a few years
back now with the president and the Iran
nuclear deal his pulling out yes
absolutely
I mean none of this was necessary Donald
Trump decided to leave a deal that was
working he decided to declare an
economic war on Iran to try to prevent
the country from exporting any oil Iran
stayed patient for a year and then they
began to retaliate with a variety of
attacks that we've seen you know this is
no justification for what they've done
but we have to understand how it started
Donald Trump started this cycle of
escalation if there is a war it is
Donald Trump's war but Barbara wasn't a
sulemani killing Americans long before
they pulled out of that deal yes but you
know the United States actually worked
with the Kurds force indirectly to get
rid of the Taliban in Afghanistan the
problem started when the u.s. invaded
Iraq in 2003 and when people like John
Bolton said Iran should take a number
implying that Iran's regime would be
next to fall then the Kurds force became
the enemy of the United States and then
they began to support groups in Iraq
that killed Americans you have to know
the history this is not one-sided
Barbara 10 seconds here who are the
biggest losers biggest losers people of
the Middle East people of Iran people of
Iraq people of Lebanon they were
beginning to push back against some of
these policies and now the subject will
be changed to the United States and what
the United States has done all right
Barbara Slavin thank you
you